Some people are so full of life and and energy,
but for some reason
even when you seem to get more than enough sleep,
you're still fighting off yawns and fatigue through the day.
So, why are you always tired?
If you the number of the hours of sleep isn't the problem,
the second most common cause of fatigue
comes from lack of physical activity and a poor diet.
Study after study finds that adults
who began light exercise a few times a week reported more energy after six weeks.
People who exercise more regularly also report sleeping better.
Even though studies show that they aren't sleeping any longer.
But if that doesn't help, don't go straight to your cup of joe.
While many studies show that coffee is good for your health
research show that your reliance on it can make you more sleepy.
Caffeine blocks adenosine in your brain
which normally accumulates through the day
and makes you sleepy at night.
But consuming coffee or energy drinks less that 6 hours before bed
can ultimately affect your sleep quality.
As a result people who don't use caffeine
often report feeling less tired in the morning.
You might consider making sure you're fully hydrated with some water first too.
One study found that a drop of 1.5% in our bodies normal water levels
can cause difficulty concentrating.
Your blood thickens which slows down nutrients and oxygen
getting to your muscles and organs.
However a 2% drop is enough to make you feel thirsty
so while there's no need to gulping down gallons of water.
Staying hydrated throughout the day will certainly help.
Urine should be pale yellow.
Any darker and it's time for some water.
Those glasses of wine or beers before bed
may also be affecting your day.
Studies have found that after becoming intoxicated
while test subjects would fall asleep faster
their quality of sleep was actually much lower,
particularly during the second half of their night sleep.
Ultimately alcohol reduces the amount of REM sleep you get.
And, if you're binge drinking and sleeping in on the weekends
be aware that a consistent sleep schedule is key.
Try waking up close to your normal time on weekends
and having short 20 minutes naps in the day.
These will still recharge your body without going into deep sleep
and making you more tired.
You're also more likely to fall asleep at a correct time on Sunday evening
making Moday morning easier.
Of course your mental well-being plays a role too.
Anxiety is a big one.
Worrying what people think, always feeling tense about work
or being overly concerned about every decision
can be physically exhausting.
And fatigue is one of the main symptoms of generalized anxiety disorder.
Not only that, but anxiety may be affecting your sleep quality.
On another serious end, depression can cause physical, and emotinal fatigue
which more sleep won't necessarily relieve.
For some it causes insomnia
or inability to fall asleep in the first place.
Unfortunately there's no quick fix for the 10% of Americans
who do suffer from depression.
So if you think you may be depressed
see your physician or psychologist.
Finally, you might also simply be a night owl.
Around 20% of population have genetics
making them predisposed to staying up late.
But living in our nine-to-five world may make it difficult for you
to get the proper amont of sleep.
In fact, scientists call this phenomenon social jet lag.
Well night owls feel like they're living in the wrong time zone every day.
If nothing seems to help, there may be an underlying medical condition
causing your fatigue which should be talked about with your physician.
Got a burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments or on Facebook and twitter
and subscribe for more weekly science videos.